MARCUS DEMNERT: Ahoy, captain!
What are you doing there?
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Arr!
I'm trying to build a Docker
image for this old Java
application that I have.
It's a great application that
keeps track of all my fishing
routes.
Let me tell you about
those, by the way.
MARCUS DEMNERT: Trim
your sails, Captain.
Why don't you use Jib for that?
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Jib?
Jib?
I know all about sails--
genoas, spinnakers, topsails!
MARCUS DEMNERT:
Hang on, Captain.
Jib is a tool that builds
containers for your job
applications without needing
much knowledge of Docker
best practices.
FREDRIK GORANSSON:
Shiver me timbers!
Tell me more about these
newfangled trickery.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARCUS DEMNERT: Take me
to your helm, Captain.
FREDRIK GORANSSON:
You mean my terminal?
MARCUS DEMNERT: Yeah, right.
Let's start with the
basic "Ahoy, world!"
Java application.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Oh, you mean
a "Hello, world!" application.
MARCUS DEMNERT: Yeah.
Let's go and grab a sample
application from the web.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Oh,
I know just the one.
When do we comb this?
MARCUS DEMNERT: So Jib
works great with both Gradle
and Maven.
I'll show you how to do
it with Gradle today.
OK, Captain?
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Oh, you
run a tight ship, sailor.
Let's do that.
MARCUS DEMNERT: First,
let's take a look
at the Jib page online.
The Gradle quick start shows
you how to get started.
Super easy-- just
add the plug-in
to your build.gradle file.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Arr, but
where should I put that code?
MARCUS DEMNERT: Put it directly
after that build script entry.
That's all you need.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Well,
that's smooth sailing, sailor.
MARCUS DEMNERT: Now,
let's build that.
Just type "gradle jib".
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Narr!
Pirates!
That did not work, sailor.
MARCUS DEMNERT: I forgot
to say, not only does Jib
build the container image.
It also sends it to a container
registry of your choice.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Oh,
I keep all my containers
on the ship, sailor--
I mean Google Cloud
Container registry.
MARCUS DEMNERT: OK, that's good.
Now, just add the image
argument to the same command.
FREDRIK GORANSSON:
Well, that was easy.
MARCUS DEMNERT: That's
all there is to it.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Ship shape
and Bristol fashion, sailor.
MARCUS DEMNERT: Let's try
it out locally with Docker.
FREDRIK GORANSSON:
Oh, I know this one--
"docker run".
Now, let's shake
as in shipshape.
I'm going to go to the localhost
and check that the app is
running through Docker.
MARCUS DEMNERT: So now that
you have your container image,
you can run it anywhere
you can run containers,
like Kubernetes.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Kubernetes?
Did you know that Kubernetes
means "helmsman" in Greek?
Now, that's another
funny nautical reference
we put in this script.
MARCUS DEMNERT: Thanks, Captain.
Anyway, that's how easy Jib
makes it to containerize
your Java application.
No Docker mastery needed.
FREDRIK GORANSSON: Arr.
Now, don't forget to subscribe
for more great Google Cloud
Platform content.
[MUSIC PLAYING]